the city of henderson has launched a  brand new campaign focusing around pool  safety it is called safe pools rule and  it is centered around preventing  drownings today the city henderson fire  and henderson hospital staging this mock  drowning to illustrate how fast one can  happen they also offered some key tips  to make sure you and your family is  prepared this summer  making sure that you are getting your  children swim lessons you are prepared  with cpr just knowing cpr you can save a  life these are some of the hardest calls  for a firefighter to respond to  we looked into it according to the  county last year saw 21 submersion  incidents and seven of them were deadly